live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions right here in the lobby
Jonathan and Kristen are Kirsten are
with us hey how are you guys
we're great Merry Christmas welcome this
were you from Lexington Kentucky awesome
welcome it's good to have you and you're
here to do your debt-free scream I love
it how much have you paid off we paid
off $38,000 and how long did it take you
took us three years okay
making what kind of money we started at
about 34 and we're up to about 52 now
good for you what do you guys do for a
living I'm music director and venue
producer at a church in Lexington mm-hmm
I'm an assistant property manager at a
local apartment community yeah very cool
okay good so was my answer of while ago
right did you hear my answer with the
guy with the bugs
I didn't you weren't listening I was dog
talking the property manager over here
okay I was answering a property
management question just a second ago I
think so you were too nervous you were
thinking about being on the air you
weren't listening to me
no that's fun so what kind of debt was
the 38,000 it was all student loans ah
okay very cool Sallie Mae so you guys at
$34,000 a year paying off $1,000 a month
that's beans and rice rice and beans I
was actually still in school when we
were paying that off so I was working
part-time at a restaurant and he was
starting full-time at the church you
guys were scratching and clawing at the
beginning here now towards the end you
had a little more room to pay off on it
art but but wow that's still very
impressive in three years so you were in
school so you guys got married while
you're in school yes okay I was so in
school he was gradual right and so tell
me the story
what happened what's the journey of this
well I think the cool part of it is it's
actually our my father-in-law her dad
gave us the FPU discs and we got engaged
so kind of listened to him and got on
board with it and really you know I
didn't have a lot of I wasn't planning
to do anything with my money before that
so it was cool to just hear hey here's
some good ideas it sounded like a great
idea so we just kind of got trucking ah
did that worked hard worked extra jobs
you know did did what we could to pay it
off as soon as we could so yeah very
cool well good for you guys that's
amazing
and clawing so what do you tell people
when they hear you've paid off $38,000
and student loan debt starving starting
young couple how did you do that what
are the principles what you do I know it
was a little bit hard for us because we
were just starting off married and we
didn't have anything to sell we started
off with nothing in fact we had to buy a
couple things just to get to like the
basic level of what we needed to kind of
survive and go on a lot a lot of hard
work
we both had multiple jobs once I started
in the apartment industry I continued
serving and at the restaurant and then I
also did some art commissioned and I
know Jonathan has also done multiple
things to you he played out at some
digging a lot of digging yeah okay so
what kind of restaurant were you working
in it's all good restaurant
it's an American restaurant I don't
really know how to describe it other
than that I did pretty well overall
having that extra job I mean I was
working six days a week between the
apartment community and the restaurant
that really helped to bring the income
up and then obviously having the budget
was huge for us and I know a lot of
people say that but that honestly is
what kept us on task and kept us from
spending more than what we had delegated
to spend for that month somebody's
listening and they were gonna be a
server at a restaurant like that how am
i how many hours were you working and
what were you making
I was probably working about 10 hours a
week because I was still working 40
hours a week at the other job I would
say I would make 100 150 a day depending
upon the day exactly but that extra
money all went to student loans that
sure didn't go to anything oh yes no
it's part of the plan but it's just you
can make money okay all right that's the
point well congratulations you guys how
does it feel feels great it feels really
good but yeah I actually tweeted you
about it one of the coolest things I got
to do is a month after we were debt-free
our I got a firewood delivery in the
middle of the night from a dude I found
on Craigslist and asked him how he was
doing and he said he was doing better
than he deserved and I was like mmm I
was like he's I was like what why are
you delivering firewood well it's my
second job I'm trying to pay off debt so
it was really cool to get to bless him
really big way there you go
he wasn't expecting so that's been a lot
of fun I think the giving throughout the
whole process honest so that's one thing
we tell people too is even while we were
trying to get out of debt we always gave
and made that a part of our process and
I think that just gives you gratitude
for what you have and helps you to just
be really content with where you are
when you see how much you have compared
to so many other people and we I mean we
also believe that God blesses you when
you continue to give we have found it
just some little things like I Drive a
92 Pontiac Bonneville that thing's still
kickin like it's got so much life in it
and I honestly believe that's been a
blessing because we've continued to give
there's no logical reason that cars will
be running I love it so I'm so proud of
it that's right I think one of the other
things that we always mentioned that
we've also been told it's when we would
watch some debt-free screams on the air
you know people are making in a hundred
two hundred thousand and it would be
discouraging for us sometimes because
we're like you know where we make thirty
to fifty thousand dollars and I just
want people to know it can be done with
not as high as an income you just got to
work all the much harder to do it and if
you're out there and you're not making a
hundred grand it's okay you can still
pay off you can work extra and you'll
get it done eventually there you go
that's awesome that's cool well and
Jonathan heard the code from the for
those of you they don't know with the
firewood guy if you have somebody
serving you in some way whether it's a
server or a valet or a firewood guy
whatever it is and you ask um pizza
delivery guy you ask them how they're
doing they say better than I deserve if
you're a listener to this show that's
code for they're working that job to get
out of debt and you have to give them
extra give them extra big tipper
generous yep so that's a make sure and
Jonathan knew the codes all right well
done you're exactly right that's exactly
how this happens it happens through
giving it happens through systems and
and it happens through you guys changing
the way you viewed it and you know what
else happened is you believed you could
do it mmm
you believed you could do it and and you
did it that's the neatest that you did
it yeah I love it well done all right
Jonathan and Kirsten are crazy Kirsten
Kirsten I'm sorry
Jonathan and Kirsten Lexington Kentucky
$38,000 paid off in three years making
34 to 52 how'd they do it work their
butts off count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
that's it that's it I love it I love it
I love it congratulations you guys very
very well done that's how life works you
guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others